c'est nous arrêter eric zemmour à
l'antenne dès aujourd'hui n'était pas
avec vous n'était pas vos côtés à 18 à
19 heures comment ça s'est passé raconté
aux téléspectateurs comment vous avez
appris qu'eric zemmour ne serait pas là
ce soir je crois que ça s'est décidé ce
week-end là on va le dire aux
téléspectateurs ça c'est décidé je crois
samedi
c'est tout ça s'est décidé samedi
ça a été non mais bon
téléphone
lui c'est dans les coulisses de la
décision non non pas du tout non mais je
dire oui ça s'est décidé samedi à une
discussion et ça la décision du csa a
été observé analysé et comme j'ai
torités d'ailleurs chez vous c'est que à
partir c'est très difficile à partir du
moment où le csa dit on va décompter le
temps d'antenne d'eric zemmour la
direction de canal + et du groupe canal+
et de ses news s'est dit c'est
impossible de garder et l'eczéma à
l'antenne tous les jours c'est ça en
analysant effectivement faut prendre le
temps d'analyser de regarder ce qui est
possible ou pas et finalement d'un
commun accord et se sont dit que c'est
matériellement impossible à quoi c'est
impossible parce que ça veut dire que ça
diminue du temps de parole par exemple à
à tout ce qui est divers droite d'accord
c'est à dire à base aviez bertrand c'est
à dire à valérie pécresse valérie
pécresse pourquoi si on commence à
décompter règlement donne moins de temps
qui est journaliste on donne moins de
temps de parole politique d'accord c'est
une décision à prendre et on sait très
bien dans le tout les tous les patrons
de chaînes télé de radio saint piat rien
de plus compliqué au monde que de
décompter justement et de vous d'écouter
de développer l'art que les freins
d'eric zemmour qui interviennent dans le
débat national zemo eric zemmour vous
l'avez au téléphone et vous celui qui
vous a prévenu non c'est pas lui qui m'a
prévenu la dérision au téléphone c'est
la direction n'a mais on a échangé avec
eric c'est ce qui nous a directement a
dit je ne peut plus venir assez nous
c'est terminé oui oui mais il m'a dit
qu'il regrette il m'a dit qu'il est
dépité aurait voulu continuer il m'a dit
ah oui bien sûr qu'il aurait voulu
continuer
ça a été très très difficile pour lui il
a essayé jusqu'au bout
et la direction de ces news aussi qui
l'a soutenue pendant deux ans a essayé
jusqu'au bout de trouver une solution
mais matériellement cette solution elle
était complètement impossible et il
fallait respecter à la décision du csa
donc malte malheureusement c'était une
décision difficile à appliquer
impossible après vous avez tout de suite
su qui avec zemmour serait plus à
l'antenne avec vous dès aujourd'hui
parce que ça a été oui et sion qui était
très rapide on croyait il allait finir
la semaine qu'il est peut être faire
aujourd'hui il n'a pas dit au revoir à
vos téléspectateurs donc c'est assez
brutal alors on entre nous on a décidé
ce soir avec eric zemmour jodie de se
revoir avec l'équipe des mousquetaires
pour empêcher un petit outil un petit
clin d'oeil aux téléspectateurs une
petite vidéo pour dire aux gens parce
qu'il regrette de ne pas avoir pu dire
au revoir effectivement mais à chaque
fois qu'il intervient c'est un décompte
donc à partir du moment où c'est un
décompte ça devient quand vous entendrez
que ce membre du csa vous comprenez la
décision du csa
je comprends mais je n'aurais pas voté
en ce sens d'accord je reprends parce
que je suis profondément viscéralement
pour la liberté d'expression j'ai appris
au csa la pluralité des opinions j'ai
appris au csa à défendre à la liberté d
opinion de l'autre qu'on soit d'accord
ou pas avec eric zemmour pour moi c'est
la liberté d expression de l'oreillette
200 chaînes télé 900 râlant mais c'est
surtout la liberté d'expression parce
que le csa le soupçonne de préparer sa
campagne et de faire campagne tous les
soirs sur ces nous d'ailleurs laurent
ruquier et léa salamé lui ont posé la
question plusieurs fois s qui sera
candidat à la présidentielle regarder sa
réponse
bonsoir à tous c'est une soirée un brin
particulière pour moi
pas possible qu'ils sont cons le soit
aussi
non vous avec le drapeau bleu blanc
rouge c'est pas une affiche électorale
ça elle est belle non comme affiches
électorales with vous la conseille vous
devriez là bas vous voyez donc c'est une
affiche électorale pourquoi vous lui
dites pas clairement je suis candidat
quand je voudrais être candidat je
dirais je suis candidat vous n'êtes pas
candidat pour l'instant je ne suis pas
vous vivez pas dire vous ne pouvez pas
dire ce soir je ne serai pas candidat
non je ne le dirai pas ce soir qu'est ce
qui vous manque pour vous décider en ce
qui me manque des signatures est ce que
vous demande de l'argent pour y aller
vous savez d'abord il manquera toujours
évidemment jusqu'au dernier moment il
faudra avoir les signatures il faudra
avoir l'argent savez une campagne
électorale c'est 15 millions d'euros
cela vous parler au futur et non pas au
conditionnel
donc ça veut dire j'aurais candidat
répond à la question donnez vous auriez
pu vous en feriez vous qui aimez top
français et les conjugaisons débours
vous auriez pu employer le conditionnel
vous voulez et vous venez de tôt
puisqu'il vous voulez je viens donc de
comprendre que vous êtes officiellement
candidat à l'elysée vous voulez que je
veux victor hugo on l'aurait voulu vous
a poursuivi mme mathieu qu'est-ce qui se
passe nangis l'arrivée un petit peu
lourd effectivement eric il a
juste sur la décision d'eric zemmour
d'eau qu'eric zemmour ne sera plus sur
ses news à 19 heures christine quand
c'est pas la direction que vous appelez
vous avez dit quoique ce que vous allez
faire maintenant alors maintenant comme
ce soir on a des limites et de plusieurs
plusieurs chroniqueurs mathieu bock côté
charlotte dans une grosse perte au point
et sur personne les diverses belge en
janvier kermit la grenouille que
personne ne peut repasser à
2002 tuant clientèle
jeu j'aime beaucoup ce covenant jeu
question
très divergentes avec eric zemmour mais
ce que c'était devenu quelqu'un qui
comptait pour vous et avec qui vous
aviez de l'affection bien sûr pourquoi
on est parfois oui pas moi sur mon nom
mais c'est kobe tous les jours mais je
suis en deuil je suis bien sûr je suis
désolé mais ouais pourquoi je suis en
deuil de la liberté d'expression mais
crée presque rien pas pu dire c'est un
scoop est en équilibre après ses cinq
cartes de presse je suis et je m'étonne
que la commission nationale les amis de
la commission nationale de la carte de
presse ne prennent pas position parce
que un journaliste qu'il soit
chroniqueur reporter et cetera ne se met
pas à créer un compte de campagne à
faire des affiches à voir les amis de
zemmour qui remuent ciel et terre à nous
insulter j'ai été copieusement insulté
jeudi soir ici parce que je suis passé
ici non mes amis de la commission
nationale revoyez un peu le cas zemmour
parce que vous ouvrez sinon
le revoir dans la cassure des présents
chez nous
expliquez-moi
et d'ailleurs je profite d'une chose
excusez-moi j'ai dit non non non je
vous écris wiision si on part il nous a
alors déclamé tontine de paris aux jeux
il y à rtl je n'ai pas le droit de dire
parce que je peux être inculpé bertel
pas le droit de dire mais lorsque
lorsque zemmour était sur rtl wii et
plus je le sais de l'intérieur qu'il ya
eu des pressions de la rédaction pour
qu'on les vince de l'antenne et on l'a
on a dit mais écoutez peu de temps avant
qu'il fasse sa chronique c'est le tiroir
caisse qui monte puisque l'audience
grossissait et je me souviens très bien
de discussion j'ai eu dans mon bureau au
csa en haut de la tour avec certaines
personnes alors c'est pas que france 2
c'est pas que paris première on n'est
pas ma décision
sur l'élection il se peut très bien que
le choix nous a
demandé de regarder le regarder la photo
ce la faute des journalistes non non non
président vous le savez vous le savez
très bien parce que si vous dites le
contraire non mais oui mais vous
savez si je le sais
je sais pas
merci bravo mais il est tout le monde
arabe mathieu l'arrière est classé monde
à echiré arrêté parce que hier eric
zemmour qui nous a fait une vidéo
justement juste eric petite question
mais moi vous a posé une question eric
est ce que vous pensez qu'il va se
présenter ou pas vous je pense que c'est
possible et je pense que le contraire
est possible c'est pour ça mais je ne
comprends pas pourquoi le sait ça prend
une décision définitive sur une jonction
voilà non c'est pas sûr du tout temps
qu'il l'a pas fait ce qu'ils vont en a
déjà parlé avec vous ah on en a beaucoup
parlé et il a envie il a dit qu'il en a
qu'il en a certainement envie mais aussi
parfois j'ai envie d'aller manger à tous
coups si j'y vais pas jusqu'à entre
l'envi et le faire il ya une différence
et moi je veux dire juridiquement
juridiquement il ya la salle le csa a
pris une décision alors justement et si
il voulait vraiment ils avaient tous pu
retirer comme candidat ment et qu'une
délibération
mais si la grèce avait pris une
délibération qui doit prendre pour la
présidentielle on aurait forcément des
comptes est aussi emmanuel mac mais là
on est pour
[Musique]
la règle soit tu es d'eric zemmour pour
touche pas à mon poste il en veut
énormément au gouvernement et surtout au
csssae nous disent qu'il va faire
maintenant regarde
bonsoir à tous c'est une soirée un brin
particulière pour moi pour la première
fois depuis deux ans je n'étais pas à
l'antenne de ses news la décision du csa
a rendu inéluctable la fin de l'émission
c'était d'ailleurs l'objectif poursuivi
le gouvernement en a rêvé le csa l'a
fait le dernier prétexte a consisté à me
qualifier de personnalités politiques en
sachant très bien que ce coup là serait
fatal
depuis deux ans le csa a tout tenté mise
en demeure amende d'un montant
astronomique règles loufoques comme
cette obligation d'une émission en
différé pendant ce temps là sur le
service public des journalistes
déversent sans gêne leur propagande
subventionnés par les impôts des
français sans que le csa ne s'alarme de
cette politisation outrageuse de
l'antenne c'est donc une page qui se
tourne mais nous continuerons d'écrire
la suite rejoignez moi sur ma chaîne
youtube ou j'interviendrai régulière je
viendrai aussi à votre rencontre à
partir de ce vendredi à toulon bonsoir à
tous et à très bientôt
alors il nous a dit j'ai l'impression
qu' eric zemmour il est chez magali
bernard hinault et nous avons
alors donc une chaîne youtube qui va
ouvrir dès demain pour parler aux
français le concept de sa chaîne sera la
croisée des chemins dans laquelle il
aura notamment une tournée en france
vendredi il sera toulon et le lendemain
à nice il chantera
vous la
vidéo il nous a répondu il ya d'abord il
est très malin va très vite comme
mitterrand le disions ne sort de
l'ambiguïté qu'à son détriment donc
c'est très malin je trouve inadmissible
tant qu'il n'est pas officiellement
candidat qu'on lui prix ont pour le prix
de ses livres la parole et ont usé
pourquoi parce qu'on a trouvé personne
en face de suffisamment rentre-dedans
courageux et brillant et certaines sont
contents vers le contraire mate ses
idées on lui fournit aux par la liberté
de parole n'était pas du rêve mais je
vous dis n'importe l'orangé impôts suède
et la deuxième chose c'est que même sur
le plan stratégique complètement
imbécile parce que ce qu'on voulait
édifier arrive maintenant absolue tard
avec huit ans les jours qui viennent
confidences
maintenant j'ai jamais démarré à débat
pas faire une confiance qu'elle a une
vie des contre vérités
lorsque j'ai
zappé étaient sur le bateau
rigole ce que je m'occupais des temps de
parole c'est sa
parole c'est ça la gauche était venue à
pour décompter eric brunet
en tant qu'éditorialiste ou femme
politique j'ai refusé c'était ça va
confidences et j'ai refusé
c'est à dire ça à gauche la nasa avait
déjà demandé de conduire est adroit
nicolas sarkozy d'accord on le sait ça
crée une décision spéciale pour
décompter nicolas sarkozy ça n'existait
pas avant en tant qu en tant qu'homme
politique mais pas en tant que président
la gauche était venue me voir pour des
cons terme n'est jamais dire j'avais
refusé donc audrey pulvar par exemple
qui était à gauche et qui allaient dans
les réunions du parti socialiste parler
à l'antenne je ne vois pas pourquoi on
allait commencé à décoter un
éditorialiste ça et j'avais maintenu cet
équilibre